now to haiti where tropical depression
grace caused flooding overnight in areas
already hard hit by saturday's
earthquake the storm ruined some of the
temporary shelters that were set up for
those without homes now this comes after
rescue teams spent yesterday digging
through the rubble searching for anyone
that still could be trapped underneath
more than fourteen hundred people were
killed and thousands more were hurt in
the country's deadliest quake since
2010. vladimir duty is in the capitol
with more on the story vlad it's the
last thing they need there what is the
situation today
gail right now hospitals are becoming
overwhelmed by the thousands of injured
patients and that is just the hospitals
that are still standing in the hardest
hit areas of the island many are now
piles of rubble leaving those in need of
help scrambling
in the hard-hit town of likai these
white tents serve as makeshift triage
units for some of those injured in the
wreckage
the agony of those being treated is
painted on their faces
the small hospitals there can barely
take in more patients
for those suffering the most serious
injuries a trip to bigger hospitals like
opita davontis daity in port-au-prince
is necessary medical director scott
nelson has been working here since
2010's earthquake we have many people
that are in the emergency room on the
floor and outside for lack of more space
what kind of injuries are you seeing
from these earthquake victims
with earthquakes
every type of orthopedic injury is
produced and many of these are crush
injuries
severe open fractures
dr nelson took us to the operating room
as a patient was undergoing surgery most
of these patients have had walls fall on
them sometimes seedlings fall on them
we've had a few jumping injuries even
some that came from close by here where
the earthquake wasn't so strong people
jump off of a balcony and have lower
extremity fractures from that
inside the ward it's a race to keep up
with the massive influx of patients just
three days ago this wing was under
construction and it was empty
now there's not an empty bed in the
entire ward they've seen over 100
patients in just the last 48 hours she
has a femur fracture here on the right
side and another femur fracture on the
left side
both of carlin bernard's femurs snapped
in half as she tried to escape a
crumbling market
hers is just one of thousands of
harrowing stories from haitians
suffering this tragedy
she could feel the earth shaking and she
started to run
and as she started to run she was hit by
falling debris and there was a man that
was next to her who died who's crushed
by that debris and she says that god
blessed her she's alive
caroline bernard will have two metal
rods placed into her legs and the good
news tony doctors tell us she will be
able to walk again after her surgery now
that's a much different outcome than
many of us saw back in 2010 when many
crush victims often immediately faced
amputation tony so vlad let's talk about
2010 because your reporting was powerful
then it's powerful now what are the
biggest changes that you've seen in the
response in the emergency operations
there in haiti
so sadly tony from 2010 one of the
things that i remarked when i started to
see the video coming in on saturday was
i had a hard time telling the difference
between 2010 and 2021 because nothing
has been done to ensure the safety of
haitians in the wake of that devastating
2010 earthquake the other thing tony is
the roads in the entire time that i've
been coming to haiti over the last dozen
years the roads are still insecure so we
have to helo in to the disaster zone
because the roads are either impassable
because of fallen debris or because
they're controlled by bandits all of
these issues that we're talking about
tony are man-made the earthquake is a
natural disaster that every country
around the planet faces but many of the
problems that haitians suffer through
all the calamities that they face have
been man-made tony yeah there's what we
can control and what we cannot and
there's a big difference between the two
vlad duterte continuing his exceptional
coverage in port-au-prince vlad thank
you very much